il ya plusieurs métiers fils y est con à
moi j'ai utilisé les petites briques
pour coller le petit et cuire sur le
carton vous découpez les angles je vous
ai mis ensuite les valeurs des papiers à
couper ses 10 ennemis par 10 ennemis
pour toutes les feuilles customiser son
album photo en y ajoutant diverses
décorations c'est ce que propose céline
lagarde à la tête de l'association
scrapping depuis quatre ans avec ses
ateliers de scrapbooking tu étale la
pâte tout en laissant gentiment des
petits trous ou pas comme tu le
souhaites tu teint qu'une bien ta petite
spatule ne fasse on a pas effacé ont
enlevé la pâte à certains endroits qui a
déjà l'isq une quinzaine d'adhérentes
participent aux ateliers de scrapbooking
l'occasion de coucher sur le papier au
travers des photos et des commentaires
l'histoire d'une famille là on est en
train de faire un mini album donc le moi
je suis partie sur deux pattes et
vacances saut j'ai mes filles qui sont
partis en vacances avec mamie j'ai fait
plusieurs empannages là j'ai fait un
copinage que j'ai remboursé
et puis après j'ai fait plusieurs
comptes nage pour préparer mes pages
avant de m
les différentes photos que j'aurais que
ma mère va me prendre et que je ferai
après deux ans parmi les techniques du
scrapbooking l'embossage à chaud va
embaucher à chaud donc tu mets ta
versamark celle en creux transparente
sur le tampon tc bien tamponné par tous
ensuite on va mettre la foudre tu met de
la poudre un peu partout sur ta feuille
turmel à poudre sur la feuille comme ça
on peut se permettre à dirt vidé après
et maintenant on va chauffer jusqu'à ce
que ça devienne non venue des états unis
ce loisir créatif à ses adeptes en
france où le fait main et la
personnalisation prime pour les
pratiquantes le plaisir d'avoir quelque
chose par soi même de créer quelque
chose de ses mains et optile 12e on peut
aussi offert après derrière pourquoi
choisir des doigts agiles et une bonne
créativité sont nécessaires pour faire
du scrapbooking l'association au scra
pineapp varie ses ateliers et propose
également d'autres créations comme cette
carte aller en 3d donc si on la déplie
en fait en bloquant à l'intérieur on va
pouvoir faire en sorte qu'elles se
tiennent debout
prochains ateliers proposés par scra
pin-up un home déco avec trois cadres
hexagonaux à vos ciseaux